So, market size doesn’t need to be a four-page
business school analysis. So if you went to
business school, feel free to do the analysis.
But it really is at first a back of the envelope
calculation. Is this business worth doing?
So we just kind of have you constantly
checking about three things. And let’s take
a look at the Jersey Square team and think
about how they approach this. If you
remember we asked you to talk about the
total available market or total addressable
market, which really is a fancy word to say
how big is the universe of everybody
potentially who could use the product. And
in this case they say well, even in the United
States there are 150 Americans who watch
the five major team sports in some capacity.
Okay, well, can we sell to 150 million people?
Not really, because the next thing we want to
look at is, what we call the served available
market. How many can I reach with my sales channel?
So, let’s see how the Jersey Square team
looked at the served available market.
They said in the New York Metro area,
there were 11 million people who watch
the five major sports teams in some capacity.
What they really should have done is, said
that, but then said how many of them have
a web browser and how many of them will
we actually be able to reach within some
period of time and with some semblance of
cash. And the next thing they were looking
at was their target market. Who will be
their most likely buyers?
And they did some research at Yankee
Stadium and said 11% or 12% of the served
available market showed strong interest and
they said well that means just in the New
York area 1.3 million people should be
interested in a subscription or rental. Really,
again if they were doing analysis for real,
they should have said, but how many of
them can we reach with a web browser
and then how many of them can we actually
get with our acquisition and activation
campaign. And what falls out of this,
if you actually take it to the next level,
is what’s a reasonable assumption of
year 1, 2 and 3 revenue? Just back of
the envelope.
Okay. So these are the people, gee, subscription
and half pay rental, let’s do some math. My
first year’s revenue should be $300 million.
No, I think I am being a little too optimistic.
At least you will start with a series of
calculation that you could bounce off
advisors and friends and cofounders and
say, you know, are we even in the
ballpark of making an interesting business.
One of the things to keep in mind is that
no startup has ever exceeded their optimistic
estimates of market size. So if your numbers
are coming in too low on potential customers,
I wouldn’t give up, I would just be going
back and looking at the customer segments
you are targeting and understand whether
you want to build the business or have a hobby.